my name is Jimmy Bogart you can find my
talks and presentations on my github at
github.com /j Bogart you can also follow
me on twitter @ @j bogart and i blog
about this and a lot of other topics on
my blog at also Jimmy Bogart comm so
this talk is a story of distributed
system failures and some patterns and
practices we can put into place to help
now I would say to eliminate those
failures but help to address them and
this story actually starts off with a
developer colleague of mine we'll call
him bill
mainly because that's actually his name
bill bill came to me with this really
worried look on his face like he was
almost sweating he was so worried now
bill is a pretty kind of straight-laced
even-keeled sort of person so if he
comes to me looking really worried like
some developers are pretty high-strung
and I'm like ok I'll talk him down
there's nothing really wrong but bill
comes to me with the worried look in his
face I know something is really really
wrong obviously cuz to me he says hey
I'm reviewing some code for a client
that is for an e-commerce website that's
about to get shipped and I saw some
stuff that had me really really worried
I said ok bill you know I I believe him
because again he never he never gets
worried it was it okay let's grab a
conference room put the code on the
screen and then just show me what you're
talking about just just walk me through
what you see here and study showed me
these just a little six six little lines
of code that looks so simple and
innocuous but hit a lot of really big
problems underneath the covers and so
I've kind of distilled it down to these
six lines of code now these are the most
important six lines of code in this
application because this is the part
where they click the button that says
place order and all the stuff happens to
actually take their money processor
order and do everything so if this page
doesn't work then the company doesn't
make money so it's very very important
that this that this set of code works so
I said okay bill I just walk me through
what you see here and just kind of walk
me through what's going on here
so he says okay the first thing we do as
part of processing a payment when they
click that very very important button is
first we grab the customer from the
database so they have a cart some card
information they hate place
so we're gonna go grab some information
out of the database I said okay nothing
too bad here so we're gonna go ahead and
take that customer information and the
card information and create an order
based on the cart and customer detail
it's like okay so far so good
okay now that we have their card
information we have the total now we're
going to go ahead and call the stripe
payment service to post a payment to
stripe it's like okay okay next after we
successfully call stripe we need to tell
the customer hey thank you for your
order so in this case we're using an
email service called send grid to go
send the thank-you email to the customer
now finally we actually need to notify
downstream systems to be able to
actually process the order and ship it
out the door so this case we're using
RabbitMQ to publish a message saying hey
we've we've created an order now a
downstream shipping service to actually
process it and then finally we redirect
the customer to a thank-you page thank
you for your order blah blah blah
around all of this is a database
transaction you don't see it here
because it's part of every single
request but that's one thing with you
have as part of this as well as around
all of this we have a database
transaction to make sure everything
succeeds or fails so based on these six
lines of code you should either be like
really worried about what's going on
here or very interested in how or what's
actually going to happen here
so nowhere in any of this six lines of
code did you see any kind of try-catch
like nothing nothing in here assumes
that any kind of failure can occur
everything just assumes that everything
will succeed all the time forever and
ever and there's one thing that I've
learned from building a lot of
distributed systems is that failure is
always an option for these kinds of
systems in fact like Google still goes
down Gmail can go down so if Amazon
Google and Gmail if those things can
still go down like what hope do we have
as mere developers so this code just
assumed that everything has not like
five nines or six nines of uptime it
just has 100% uptime all the time and so
like for some code that could be okay
but for something like this where I'm
calling my systems and other people's
systems then I've to start to really
think about what happens when those
other systems go
or if they fail so I had them walk
through it's okay yes there's nothing in
here that deals with any kind of
failures so let's just walk through each
of these different calls and those six
lines of code and say what happens when
each of those lines of codes fails for
whatever reason and I mean very explicit
with my language I don't say what
happens if that that system fails I say
what happens when because when
developers and especially the business
when they hear if something fails they
get these like happy years like no
nothing ever fails ever that's such a
remote possibility that let's just let's
just like sweep it under the rug and who
cares and so I'm being very explicit
assay when something fails to force
developers and our business to think
about those situations so I broke it
down we started a whiteboard everything
that's going on here and we broke it
down to those those six things that were
going on here and so I wanted to do is
basically for each line of code in there
what happens both from the system
perspective as well as the end-user
perspective when each of those calls
fails so the very first call that
happened was I would go grab information
out of the database the customer
information and then I went insert an
order so what happens when that call
fails well I don't have any trycatch
right so some exception happens but we
were wrapping everything inside a
database transaction and so the database
transaction would never actually commit
so in this case if that call fails then
the transaction rolls back not very nice
error shown to the end-user which is
still a problem right like an error
shown to you when you just put your
credit card information in is like the
worst thing you could possibly see in
fact I start to go like check my credit
card statement say Oh something failed
here so it's still not a good thing from
the end-user perspective but at least
the system is still in a consistent
state said okay now let's move on to the
next call what happens when that call to
stripe fails now we start to look at
this and say well what's a real
possibility that something like that can
actually happen but it turns out that
because we're using just a web api call
we could have the possibility that we
made a call to that API we
assume that it failed because we just
timed out from waiting for success
result to come back we said well I tried
to call stripe
I waited for 30 seconds and nothing
happened so I'll just assume and it
failed but it actually could have
succeeded so even this is a partial
success partial failure state but just
assuming that something went wrong for
whatever reason what what is the
experience for the end-user well because
we get that exception the database
transaction never commits the
transaction rolls back and we think that
no money actually is posted to the
account so so far like it's it's still
not a great experience for the end-user
right we never want to show the end-user
that yellow screen of death from asp net
right that we never ever want to show
that to the end-user especially when
they're putting in their their payment
information so it's not a great
experience for the end-user but at least
the system is inconsistent consistent
state now this is where things get
interesting what happens when syn grid
fails there he bad things start to
happen because we we made the call to
the database to insert an order we made
the call to stripe the strike call
succeeded we tried to tell the customer
about it
butts in great failed because we get an
exception the database transaction rolls
back but we still took their money so
not a good thing so the customer says oh
okay you got an error page and then I go
check my credit card statement and it
says that it paid for this so what do
they do they call customer service or
email them saying you took my money but
where's my stuff where's my order the
customer service rep or admin goes and
looked in the system and finds there's
no order again not a good not a very
good state to be in at this point the
customers mad the probably going to go
on to Yelp and right and really bad
things about your business all because
we didn't have anything that dealt with
that failure over there
what about rabbitmq this is where things
start to really get bad by the way so in
this case the call to the database
succeeded initially but the transaction
rolls back so again we don't have any
record of their order except probably
some logs I guess like that's when you
know things are really bad eBay store I
have to go with
log to see where that order was we took
their money and we told them about it
via send grid but we have no record of
the order so well we never notify any
downstream systems they have an email
saying hey you you actually took my
money and you said here's the order but
when we go look up at the order in the
database it doesn't exist so again a
very very bad state to be in expect lots
of bad Yelp reviews from this as well
and the final really bad thing that can
happen is what happens when the database
transaction fails
now this can still happen on occasion
let's say we have like database
constraints or just some kind of hiccup
happens talking to the database in fact
if you've ever used as your sequel you
have to really just expect failures all
the time with that in fact some of the
connection providers will just retry
like five times because the connections
could be so spotty there so we even
though like in in real life we may
expect transactions to always succeed
and practice those transactions can fail
so in this case what's the experience
for the end user
well we charge the customer and we told
them we charged them and said thank you
for your order and we notifying
downstream systems but the transaction
rollback so there is no record the order
so at this point the systems state is
royal royal EF at this point there's no
record of the order in the database
downstream systems we're trying to
fulfill an order that doesn't exist
whatsoever and so basically everyone is
mad at us because of the things we've
done here so we we walked three to this
lake okay maybe we can deal with the
stripe failure but as we start to touch
more and more systems the system gets
more and more in a bad state and so at
this point bill and I are like okay what
do we do now
right now what's our strategy for
dealing with failures I mean like well
we'll try again next time but this like
shrugging your shoulders and like yeah
it can't actually fail it's probably not
good for business and again this is when
you start to see things show up I'm like
front page of hacker news because all
these things went wrong I have friends
that have built systems just like this
and they've lost thousands and thousands
of dollars because of these kinds of
failures so just like shrugging their
shoulders and just
everything succeeds it's probably not a
good idea now the main problem is that
we had this database transaction that
kept the database transaction consistent
but it didn't touch any of the other
systems that we were talking to so what
if we can just kind of extend that
boundary that transaction I'm just like
map all the way over to all the other
systems were talking to that would be
nice if that was possible or feasible
but in reality none of those other
systems will support anything like this
concept of a distributed transaction and
in fact a performance if you ever try to
do this Zoomer here ever try to do that
the old like WS extensions the
webservice extensions that try to do
this let's see there was WS transactions
WS reliable messaging WS reliability
like they try three or four times to
build a web service protocol to be able
to do this they all failed spectacularly
and so this is just not really possible
and on top of that to try to achieve
this is such a big performance hit that
no one even attempts to try to do this
anymore so we can't just put the entire
world in a transaction that's not how
the real world works anyway so we just
can't try to just extend that line out
there so instead we have to build our
systems in the communication to assume
that these different calls will fail and
then plan for the worst according to
what happens when those other things
fail so luckily for us there are much
smarter people that had seen these kinds
of problems and distributed systems and
had delineated different options for how
to deal with these different kinds of
failures and the classic paper on this
is from Gregg our hope I think it's how
you pronounce it it original paper was
Starbucks doesn't use two-phase commit
I think Starbucks noticed that and said
please don't use our name and this weird
paper and so now it's your coffee shop
doesn't use two-phase commit and in this
paper he walks through a real-world
scenario of you walking into maybe not a
Starbucks but a coffee shop and then how
those coffee shops deal with a messiness
of a distributed system which is you the
person buying something the cashier as
well as maybe someone also processing
the order or may
can your coffee behind-the-scenes that's
that's a much Messier system than just
you know a single in process operation
and so you looked at that real world
system and said when things fail between
these different handshakes and handoffs
what are the different options for
dealing with those failures so given any
two resources where I have to coordinate
some kind of activity what are the four
different ways we can address those
different failures option one if I'm
trying some operation with resource a
and another up and then in some action
with resource B is to just simply ignore
the failure so if resource B action
fails just ignore it for whatever reason
now you might say like well we didn't we
just say we don't want to ignore
failures right we want to take people's
money so this may not that may not be an
option for a lot of the different
systems we talk to but it could be for
example do you want your system to go
down because you can't write to your log
probably not so if something goes wrong
with logging you probably still want to
be able to take people's money so there
are some cases where we will be talking
to external systems where we just don't
care if those other systems fail they're
not critical for the business option two
is to retry that operation that is I
perform some operation with resource a I
do some action with resource P it fails
and instead of giving up on it I just
try it again now there's a lot more
detail behind being able to do retries I
have to worry about can that operation
actually be retried in the first place
so we have to do some investigation to
make sure that if I try that operation
again
it can actually be retried we also have
to worry about what happens if I retry
and it fails again
do I just retry forever probably not so
we will have to think about how we want
to handle a case where something is
constantly failing like what ifs in
grade went down for a day do we just
retry and retry retry with all these
processes hung probably not so have to
worry about some kind of policy around
how we retry the next option is to have
some kind of undo action that is I try
an action with resource a I try an
action of the resource B resource B
fails so I perform some kind of undo
with the action from resource a now this
could be something like a database
transaction rollback but it may not and
may be some kind of compensating action
where I'm undoing I'm taking a new
action to undo the action of that
previous thing now the final one is the
most complicated one which is to have
this idea of a coordinated transaction
between these two resources now there's
lots more arrows in this one but the
basic idea is that I split my my
coordination into two phases one is the
prepare phase and one is the commit
phase and each resource is talking back
to some kind of coordinator to be able
to handle and manage that communication
and those different operations now
you've actually have probably seen this
in real life if anyone here has had to
purchase an apartment or purchase a
house that operation of you going and
buying it involves this coordinator and
these these transactions and these this
two phases approach so if I'm going to
buy a house there's usually some kind of
a third party broker involved and
there's usually some kind of deposit
there's also an agreement on the seller
that says yes I want to sell this for
this amount and so this third party
coordinators is talking to each of the
interested parties to say yes do you
want to sell this house at this price do
you want to buy this house at this price
yes you do yes you do okay now let's go
ahead and sign all the papers so this is
a possibility in the case where each of
these different resources can have this
kind of communication but it does come
at a cost and expense in the real world
the cost is like money I have to pay
this third party to be able to just like
watch me sign papers but in our
distributive systems land you can see
that the more there arrows are going
around the more communication that has
to happen and so there's a there's an
overhead to be able to do something like
this it also introduces the possibility
of more failures that can happen so I
want to make sure that all those arrows
are very solid and not like a like a
broken line arrow or a dotted arrow that
that these things can these things will
absolutely succeed it's not a bullet
proof protocol either in that second
round after I do the commit
if that second commit to the second
resource fails then again the system is
in a inconsistent state so it's not
perfect but it can be able to provide
this kind of coordinated transaction
between two different resources so these
are our four options dealing with
failures between two different resources
so bill and I had a master plan where we
take each of those external resources
examine the possibilities based on those
four different option and pick the best
option based on what was technically
feasible as well as what was most
desirable from the business perspective
now this is where you do actually have
to involve the business in your
discussions you can't just decide oh
well we'll just do a retry because that
may have implications for the end-user
as well see and anytime we're affecting
the end-user experience we do need to
involve the business to say hey you know
if we retry this the user may see this
in their bank account that sort of thing
so we need to make sure that we we
involve the business and these
discussions Oh more systems failures
next door all right all right first up
was stripe so four options again our
ignore retry undo and coordinate so the
first up is to ignore again just a
reminder these are the six lines of code
we had before so what would it what
would look like to ignore a failure of
stripe probably like a try-catch around
calling stripe and then when the
exception happens just swallow the
exception but we kind of want people's
money you know we we do need to get
their money too in order to fulfill the
order so just like ignoring failure from
stripe it's probably not we want to do
and in fact I don't think I'd even talk
to the business about this they just
give you this weird look like why are
you coming to this or I come to me with
this option just get out of my office so
we probably don't want to just ignore
fail payment however I bet that you have
seen this in real life I bet you have
seen a case where a payment failed and
the business is like don't worry about
it you're good it's okay I've seen this
sometimes especially in places where
that credit card machine fails like you
can't connect because of whatever reason
and the person that's performing that it
has an option like well do I just go
ahead and give them the
food or dye say no we need to wait for
other payment or you have to give me
cash that sort of thing
so in our electronic world I probably
don't want to ignore it but in the real
world this kind of thing does happen
option two is a retry now this is where
we have to be careful because if I'm
making a call to stripe remember we said
that even though the stripe call may
have failed from our perspective that
doesn't mean it actually failed on the
server side because we could have called
stripe and waited 30 seconds for a
minute for a response nothing came back
and we said well I guess it failed
because they didn't get back to me but
it could have meant that I waited 30
seconds to not 31 seconds or 60 seconds
so not 61 seconds because it actually
did succeed on the server side so in
this case really we need to make sure
that if I call the stripe again that it
don't accidentally charge the customer
twice because that's almost worse than
not charging them at all right
like have you ever seen getting double
charged you're probably gonna be
somewhat upset and again Yelp bad
reviews etc etc so when you're dealing
with looking at retries you have to know
how to Google for how to be able to do
this and the key word here for retries
in order to be able to try something
more than one time and have it only
happened once is idempotent or
idempotency the idea behind idempotency
is that I can try some operation
multiple times and the side effect only
happens once or I can try something
multiple times and it only happens once
so when I Google like little goo is
stripe idempotency their documentation
come up it says yes we do support this
and the idea behind idempotent requests
is stripe doesn't can't really tell one
request from the other so if I have
someone posting the same payment twice
I can't just look at the information and
just assume that it's going to be a
duplicate so if it sees the same name
the same price around the same time
stripe still want to assume that that's
the exact same request it could just
mean that someone just like click really
fast or something so I have to tell
stripe that this this request has some
sort of unique identifier to identify
this attempt at payment or
something else in the future so this is
a an artificial idempotency as opposed
to a natural item potency so if I tell
someone to turn the light on I can tell
them multiple times and if they the
lights already on there's nothing for
them to do in this case there's no sort
of natural item potency that's there so
stripe says you have to tell me some
kind of unique key or identifier that
said distinguishes this payment versus
something else so we looked at this
request and said what is distinct about
this transaction versus some other
transaction and we need to pass that
information over to stripe to this item
potency key header so we looked at the
request and said what is what is the
thing that distinguishes this business
transaction versus someone just clicking
really fast and putting something in the
cart and hitting place order again and
it came down to the cart ID you could
also use the order ID but it's basically
something that represents this logical
order that I can then pass over to
stripe to say if I happen to call stripe
servers twice with the same cart ID or
order ID then it only processes that
payment once but you have to explicitly
do this so by the way if you're using
stripe today like do look at this
because if someone double clicks or
something like that this will catch
those of those problems and just make
sure that the customer only gets charged
once because you have people like my
mother who double clicks everything on
the web everything now this this just
allows this to be retried but you don't
see any code around here that actually
performs the retry so we still to figure
out like well what what is actually
making a calling this over again so
there's none of that here we just said
well we're able to do a retry and then
we'll figure out how the retries
actually happened sometime in the future
option 3 is undo now this one is a
little bit trickier because you have to
think about what is the logical undo or
compensating action for whatever action
you were performing and so there's
nothing really like easily Google with
this you just have to kind of think what
is the action in performing and is there
an equal and opposite action that you
can do to undo the actions that you did
previously so in our case we're looking
at stripe
is a logical undo of posting a payment I
can have like there's a credit versus
debit accounts in this case I'm posting
a payment and so their concept of
undoing a posted payment is a refund a
refund is a call that you make to stripe
where we give it the original payment ID
and it will post the payment back to
that person's account from that exact
same amount so it would look something
like this where I would have that same
set of code where I was trying to call
all these different services and if
something fails then what I'll do is go
ahead and call stripe again to refund
the payment there's still something
missing here though because I had that
that transaction that was around
everything so in this case I'll actually
pull in the transaction as part of this
operations well I'll say begin the
transaction do all your stuff commit the
transaction and if something fails then
I will say go ahead and cause the stripe
service to refund the payment and a
rollback of database transaction now I
know some of you are looking at this and
says well what happens Jimmy said I
should never see what happens if
something fails what happen when
something fails what happens when the
stripe service refund fails ok let's go
on to option 4
I mean you guys they like you it just
starts to getting a rabbit hole of all
these different things that can fail so
we would have to worry about that in the
future as well okay option four is
coordinating now we said earlier that
most modern web services aren't built
with any kind of like transactional
support in mind it's assumed that
whenever I call the API that there is a
transaction behind the scenes but I
can't coordinate like more than one call
NORC i coordinate this call with some
other thing that's going on I can't
coordinate a transaction with stripe and
syn grid that's just not possible so it
looked at this and said well did it have
some kind of like some kind of
coordinated activity that's a two-step
flow where I prepare the payment and
then then actually commit the payment
later on and it turns out they do
actually support this it's called a
two-step payment flow if you've ever
gone to a hotel where they ask for your
credit card they'll put a charge on it
for like I didn't it my nights room or
something like that but it won't
actually post to your account if you log
in to your account it said it will say
pending transaction and that transaction
will be pending for like your the length
your stay and then when you check out
they'll either deduct whatever that
you've purchased or they'll just remove
that authorized payments and it never
gets posted to your account so we could
do this where we have a two-step payment
flow in this case what we'll do is we
can call stripe initially to authorize a
certain amount and then after everything
else has succeeded then we'll go ahead
and post the payment so it looks
something like this way I had the same
triquetra on everything but this time I
said image just me posting a payment
I'll first post an authorization to
payment to pay something and then if
everything succeeds then later on I will
go ahead and post the capture down at
the bottom now again we said what
happens when this second call fails
actually if that call fails we're
actually in not a bad state because if
something happens here I can log
something and then the then the stripe
administrator can log into the stripe
admin user interface and they can see
all the striped payments that have not
succeeded and they go and say you know
capture capture capture capture for all
of those so it is able to kind of be in
this half
okay States and then administrator can
then go
fix things later on okay so that was
stripe no stripe is gonna look a lot
different from the options that we'll
see from cengage SendGrid and RabbitMQ
because stripe is a you know it's about
money right so we want to make sure that
those things are very successful but
sing great of rabbitmq are very
different they have a lot they've a lot
different guarantees that we'll have for
their services and they're optimizing
for different kind of usage scenarios so
looking at syn grid option one would be
to ignore this now this is where we can
go to our business and say what happens
if syndra's goes down is it okay if we
still process the order do we want to to
fail the entire order process if I can't
send them an email saying thank you for
your order business may say no or they
may say yes I don't know um usually
they'd say no like I don't want to like
I don't want to prevent my business from
taking money if I can't just email
people that seems a bit silly so in this
case our ignore could be a viable option
so it looks something like this where
instead of me calling the same grid
service directly what I'll do is I'll
wrap it in a try-catch where I'll try
the send grade service and if something
fails I'll just log an exception if I do
need to actually send the order email
success email outs then it made to do
some more processing like flag the order
or needing an email or something like
that to have something processing behind
the scenes but the general idea is that
I don't couple myself in this case to
send grits up time if syn grid is down
it'll just go on and keep on going
option two is a retry so you can google
this you go send grid idempotency send
great retries and what you'll find is a
lot of Stack Overflow questions with no
answers but like 20 comments which
that's a bad place to be in right like
if you google something and Stack
Overflow has no answers but just
comments like I'm in trouble then so
there's no such thing as item potent
requests force in grid there's a good
reason for this so syn grid optimizes
for speed so when you call send grid
it's going to send that email as fast as
possible now
about stripe now stripe I want to be
able to handle like calling the API
multiple times so every time I call it
if I pass in that that key it's gonna
have to look up in its list of
transactions have I charged this
customer before now syn grid if it's
optimizing for speed I just want to make
these lookups to say oh have you sent
this email before let me go check oh
there it is
don't send the email out so force in
grid that's that's not part of its
business model so it's not going to
allow these retries so if I call send
grit twice those emails will get sent
twice so we don't want to call send gray
twice unless we're ok with duplicate
emails now this is where I get I talk to
the business and I ask them would you
rather have at like zero or one email
sent out so like it either succeeds or
fails and if it fails I don't send me
out or would you want to have at least
one email gets sent out so if I try it
more than one time there's a possibility
that the user gets more than one email
and of course the business says neither
I wanted to happen exactly once
but distributive systems there's no such
thing as exactly once we can try to put
that in there but it's just impossible
so we're left with this choice of do we
want at most one email go out or at
least one email and have to leave it to
the business to decide which one is the
most appropriate option option 3 undo as
much as I would like to be able to undo
emails we can't unsend emails right
there's no I like click the button I
guess Gmail has this now doesn't it
liking an unsent an email and how does
it do that well it just doesn't send the
email right away it just waits 10
seconds to say I won't send this email
right away Steve about 10 seconds to
change your mind and if you changed your
mind
I won't unsend it I just won't send it
at all
but we can't we can't retract emails as
much as I want to so what's the what's
the compensating action here sorry we
screwed up I've had to send these emails
before the I'm sorry I screwed up emails
to customers it's not fun but that is a
compensating action from the business we
can do sorry about the problem let us
compensate you with a
coupon or it'll compensate you with
bonus points or something like that so
we could have some kind of business of a
compensating action but not from the
like low technical perspective option
for coordinates I don't even know what
that means for email like how would you
call like I'm gonna put my finger on the
email and then I'm gonna do the
transaction if when this thing succeeds
I'll lift my finger off the email and
then you get sent out the door like that
that's not a thing that happens with
email so there's like there's nothing
for this
[Music]
finally it's RabbitMQ now RabbitMQ is
gonna be very very similar to email
because RabbitMQ deals with messages so
kind of a very similar kind of options
available for us but our decision about
what to do may be different because in
this case the things we do with RabbitMQ
may be more important than just sending
someone an email so option one would be
to ignore this would look again like I
have a try-catch around trying to talk
to rabbitmq and if something fails then
I still need to notify downstream
systems so what I'll do is I'll just
flag the order as needing to have this
thing sent out the door so that's some
kind of like maybe a background process
looks for orders they needed to have
their message sent out the door and then
it just once a day or or maybe once an
hour or whatever it might be looks for
those orders and then go ahead and
finishes this operation so this could be
a possibility for us but we still need
to have something that is sending those
messages out the door option two is a
retry so rabbitmq and some brokers do
have a concept of a retried many one
here is used as your service bus as your
service bus has duplicate message
detection you have to turn it on and
what we'll do is we'll keep track of
messages for a certain period of time
like thirty seconds five minutes some
kind of configurable amount of time and
what it'll do is every time I call to
send a message it will check to see if
it sent any of those messages in the
last amount of time and if you already
have and won't send a message however
just like the web service if I wait
longer than that then that message will
get sent out the door so in this case
like rabbitmq doesn't support that kind
of operation
so rabbiting queue doesn't have a
concept
or retry if I try a message again in
RabbitMQ it will get sense again now
rabbitmq doesn't have any concept of
retries so i don't have to worry I don't
think about what RabbitMQ is going to do
with those retries i have to think about
what all those downstream consumers are
going to be able to do with duplicate
messages coming in so this is one of
those things like I don't if I don't
have control over these other consumers
of these messages then I may not be able
to do retries at all and just say I
can't guarantee that those downstream
systems will be able to handle duplicate
messages so this may not be a
possibility for us option 3 is undo just
like email so we can't unsend a message
I can't like take the message back and
like notify everybody oops I'm sorry
please don't do well like ignore that
last one and then a compensating message
would be I would be weird I have the
order placed event and then right after
that like haha just kidding order wasn't
really placed events that's not a thing
that people do and so in this case the
compensating message could be would be
weird there are cases where this does
happen let's say that I have an order
that was placed
but then the customer calls and said I
made a mistake can you cancel that order
and then depending on where the order is
in the order process
I'll have different actions I can
perform so like from the business
perspective they may be able to do
something like this that's where we
start to come in to different policies
and business rules around the each of
these different actions option for
coordinates revenue q does not support
this no no real broker out there
supports this kind of operation any more
of coordinating transactions some of the
more older brokers and Q's do but they
perform horribly so you when using
something like MSM q and sequel server
you can actually coordinate a
transaction for both of those resources
but it's like 10 times slower when you
do so so for our systems that's not a
performance hit we're willing to take
and so for for modern brokers they just
don't support this kind of operation at
all because it's such an expensive thing
to do so looking at all the different
services and all the different options
like there's not any consistency about
what things are supported between each
different ones and the
this rules are now getting really wonky
about all these different things and if
I tried to encode all of this into that
one six set of six lines of code be
these like nested try caches and if
something fails over here then I have to
do some operation over there but if that
still fails then like oh god we still
recover from that so this is where Bill
and I took a step back and we said this
is getting too complicated like maybe
the maybe the main problem here is not
that these things can fail at any point
time they may be the main problems that
we're trying to do all of these
operations in a single button click
we're trying to do too much when a user
clicks that button so can we avoid
exceptions by braking in this process
coupling and stop trying to do so much
in the concept on context of a single
button click now I've actually worked in
e-commerce I've worked on a very large
calm web site in the cart checkout
operation and so I know like what real
businesses do with this and what we'll
be describing from here on out is how
these large organizations actually solve
this process coupling so in order to
figure out what things can be broken out
we have to look at each of these
different operations and ask the
business does this thing need to happen
when the button is clicked or can it
happen sometime in the future and that's
not again a decision that I can make as
a developer but I have to pose that
question of the business can we do do I
have to do this now or can we do it
sometime in the future do we have to do
it when they click the button or do we
have some kind of background process or
they can take up these things the first
up is stripe so this is again a business
discussion because in some cases we may
need to try to charge the customer when
they've clicked a button but there are
other cases where we may not want to
Amazon for example they don't charge you
when you click that button there's some
kind of background thing that works to
be able to do that and the reason why
they have that is because they have like
effectively infinite supply or inventory
and so there's no need to say like well
I can only allow a certain number of
people to be able to buy this thing so I
need to make sure that when you click
the button that I take your money right
at that point in time but there are
other cases where the they do try to
take your money at that
time so something that has a very finite
amount of resources so something like a
movie ticket where I'm picking a seat
where I want to sit so the case they
want to make sure that the business from
the business perspective they're only
selling seats to people that actually
pay so in that case they'll do things
like have that little timer that
stresses me out that's counting down
from five minutes it's like you must
pick your seat and put all the
information in there and what they're
doing is we receipts and making sure
that you can actually pay when you hit
the button but in our case in this
actual real-world application we
wouldn't talk to the business of like
you know it would be nice if we could
take their money but it's not required
if you won't have to take the money at
that point in time so in this case what
we did was we did a try where we said
we're gonna try to take the money and if
something fails then we'll just mark the
payment has failed and then some kind of
background processor will be looking for
orders with failed payments and then
what we can try to retry them at that
point in time
next up with sim grid we ask the
business so what what is sin grid that
need to be actually connected to what is
this what is the thing in this process
that should kick off or initiate me it's
emailing the customer so I said is it
when they when we insert an order into
the database is that the thing that
should kick off this email to the user
like no not really it's not like it's
not as important that we just we have
the order it's actually when they pay
for it that we should then send the
email out so is that okay is there a way
for us to connect syn grid with stripe
so that when a syn grid payment is
successful then we go ahead and send the
email and we can do this using web hooks
you can also do this if you use things
like logic apps or what's whatever the
Amazon version of this or if this than
that these kind of like event-driven
widgets that says when this thing
happens go do this other thing
and so we looked at stripe it has the
ability of a web hook that says every
time a stripe payment is successful call
this API over here and then you can do
whatever you want that API call
unfortunately for our real world
scenario this wasn't this wasn't good
enough for us
so while it's nice that it's there we
needed to have more kind of business
logic that happen for the email and so
what this wasn't an appropriate solution
for us
the final one was RabbitMQ we said when
I when I create this order do I need to
do I want to couple the uptime of
rabbitmq to me processing this order and
again this is a question for the
business we do need to Nutini Sinise
message out eventually but they're not
necessarily case I have to do it at this
point in time so the way we can separate
out RabbitMQ from our database
transaction is to use an outbox pattern
and now it backs pattern my stab would
basically store the messages temporarily
in our database so when I create the
order I'm not just inserting the order
information I'm also inserting messages
into like a messages table and then
something behind-the-scenes is looking
in the database for messages to be sent
and then we'll send them out the door
via rabbitmq so in code it would look
like this where instead of me calling
bus dot publish and said I'm inserting
something into our database that is that
message is eventually going to get sent
out the door and then some kind of
background processor is going to look
for any kind of unsent messages and then
we'll actually take the messages off the
database and send it out the door via
RabbitMQ again we were still not quite
there because we looked at all like let
me look at that final set of code it was
still just not very explicit about what
all the things that were happening there
and it's just again a bunch of try
caches and write everything else so we
looked at said we're just we're still
just doing way way too much in the
context of a single button click and if
we looked at modern ecommerce systems
modern ecommerce uses background
processing to actually fulfill the
orders so what we need to do is
introduce some kind of workflow to
manage the process that given the order
and remove as much responsibility as
possible from that initial button click
but as part of this we're still going to
have some constraints around these
different operations so I looked at each
of the different services we were
talking to and said what are the what
are the things that need to happen
as part of each individual item so
stripe we said do we need to do this now
or can we process this offline so in the
case of stripe our business said we want
to minimize the checkout fallout rate
the fallout rate is someone that starts
the checkout process and then abandons
it and says too much junk is going on I
tried it for this thing blowing up at me
whatever so in this case what we'll do
is try to minimize that as much as
possible by moving the stripe processing
from the button click and doing that
offline instead this is what we actually
did in my real calm ecommerce experience
we even turned off all validation like
all of it you're there's annoying things
you'd see the credit card if you
accidentally switched to numbers it's
like that's not a valid credit card
number it's called the lunch accor the
Loon cheque there's a there's a built-in
checksum into credit card numbers that
you can use to check to see if it's a
valid credit card number or not users
hate to see that message because like
they thought they entered it in right
and they just switched to numbers and
it's saying that's not a valid credit
card number like yes it is so now I have
to take your credit card out like put it
up next to the screen be like oh there's
where I messed up right there so when I
worked in calm our e-commerce we just
turned all that off like all of it so
there's someone messed up hitting in
their credit card we would call them
sometime in the future say oops we
couldn't process your credit card
payment and actually talk to a human to
be able to then finish that order send
grid and rabbitmq are very similar and
that we don't have there's no there's no
requirement to process these are to do
these things and the context of the
single button click so all these things
we're not actually required to do the
concept and the context of that one
single button click so these things now
need to be coordinated and some kind of
background process or a workflow so
let's go to see I'm gonna skip this
actually starting that yes so it looks
something like this we'll have requests
come in and the only thing that thing
does now is just insert a row into the
database and then something is then
pulling those information off the
database and kicking off some kind of
processor behind the scenes some kind of
order processor that then coordinates
the activities between these different
back-end services now at this point we
need to figure out like what is that
workflow look like we didn't want to go
like buy a workflow solution off the
shelf it's too expensive so we'll be
writing code to figure out how to
and process the orders and there are a
few different workflow patterns off the
shelf that we can look at to be able to
process those orders effectively the
first pattern is known as the routing or
routing slip pattern if I'm in the UK
the routing slip pattern is this idea
that I have a message with all the
different destinations and then that
message just flows from one endpoint to
the next until it reaches its final
destination so it looks something like
this
we're that background task would post
the message first to the stripe
messaging in point one stripe finishes
processing it gets forwarded on to the
next process and then once that finishes
it go if it gets forward on to the next
one and then the thing that kicks
everything off will just say send this
message to all three of these different
endpoints now we looked at this one and
said well there's still some workflow
constraints we have like syn grid should
only happen if stripe succeeds but
RabbitMQ is a different story maybe that
doesn't have that kind of coupling
available so this enforces a very linear
flow but for us this workflow process
didn't need to have that linear flow so
it wasn't a very good fit another
pattern is the saga pattern and the
sangga pattern the canonical example is
a booking holiday and the general idea
is you can't coordinate the transaction
of all the different parts of booking a
holiday into one single transaction so
if I'm booking a rental car looking a
hotel booking of flights you can't get
like a conference call with all those
three people together
right like no one ever does that so
instead I have to book each individual
thing separate from each other so it
starts out with okay I'll book the
rental car that was successful next
thing we'll do is book the hotel that
was successful but if I fail and booking
a flight then what I need to do is
cancel the reservations of the other two
so this kind of simplified flow works
really well if I have compensating
actions for those different operations
but we've already seen that two of our
operations don't have compensating
actions like I can't unsend an email and
I can't unsend a message
so this saga a pattern works well for
very simple business scenarios but ours
is more complex this is not going to
work for us now the final pattern
available to us is going to be the
process manager pattern which is
basically none of the simple stuff works
and so now you're just completely up to
your own device about building out some
kind
of a workflow process so in this case
we'll have some kind of central thing
that manages the overall order
processing pipeline where it receives
notifications that a new order is ready
to be processed and is out coordinating
communication between these other
third-party services to fulfill the
entire business business order and again
we have we have another choice in front
of us what is the what does that
coordination actually look like between
that central process manager and these
other things going on behind the scenes
and from the micro services world there
are two main patterns that are
identified for this kind of process
management
they're known as orchestration and
choreography also known as like command
based versus event based command base is
gonna be very very procedural and it's
look it's gonna be some process manager
saying hey do this thing okay now I
think to go do this thing okay now a
thing through you go do that other thing
and choreography is more event based
where I just publish that in events it
gets broadcast to all the different
subscribers and then I wait to hear back
what the results of all the different
processing was and my choice between
each of these is really good in depend
on that process coupling do I need to
make sure that this thing happens first
before other things or it does it not
matter the order in which things get hot
to get processed so again I have to go
back to those lists of things that were
happening and look at the process
coupling stripe I need to make sure
happens first before I do anything else
I don't want to send a thank-you email
unless that payment was successful so in
this case I actually want to orchestrate
the call with stripe to make sure that
that thing happens first before I go do
any of the other operations send grid
I don't need a quote I don't need to tie
to anything else so force in grid and
for RabbitMQ I can actually use
choreography that is event based
notification for those so it start to
look like this we have the initial
request coming in from the outside where
all via post to our API and that set at
work the only thing that's doing is
inserting a row into a database and
that's it so I have a high
confidence that that can succeed like if
I can't infer to Road to a database then
like I can't do anything else in my
system so we want to make sure that that
operation has a high degree of success
so we'll want to make sure that that
database is highly available
maybe primary secondary or some kind of
replicated mode to really make sure that
I can insert I can I can insert rows
into a database at any point in time now
from there something then looks for
orders that need processing is going to
kick off our process manager so our our
web code now looks like this so we've
removed those six lines of code and just
basically boiled down to like three
lines of code which is first go ahead
and create the order from the card
information we'll save the order to the
database and then we'll send a message
to kick off this background process to
actually do the work so that that
message to the to kick off the set of
work is going to be sent to a process
manager to be able to take that and
actually perform the operation so the
next part is then receiving that message
and then coordinating with stripe to
actually perform that first step in the
process so in this case I'm using a
library called and service bus to make
this part easier I don't want to code
process managers by hand myself so in
this case in service bus just kind of
removes a lot of that plumbing junk to
make my life a bit easier here so it
looks something like this where I have
this process order saga which is a
process manager implementation it
received the process order command that
came from the front end it's going to do
some logging and then all it's going to
do is then send a message to the stripe
payment payment processor to go ahead
and process that order so it receives
the message from the outside and that's
going to send them send a message out to
stripe to say okay receive the order now
go ahead and process that payment then
on the stripe side it's receiving that
notification to say I would I you need
to now process this payment it's going
to make the call to stripe to process
the payment based on the information it
finds and then based on the success or
failure of that it's going to return
that back out and reply back to the
original process manager to say
this is the result of trying to process
this payment so inside that awaits type
service process payment you can probably
imagine some kind of like try-catch that
says if stripe fails then just go ahead
and return back a result of false to say
it wasn't successful and then we'll
leave it up to the process manager to
decide how to deal with failures so my
stripe processor is not the thing that's
managing what to do with failures it's
merely returning the result of the
operation to let the process manager
have all the business logic of what to
do so that reply comes back as a new
message to the process manager and the
process manager then receives that
message and they can make a decision so
if I want to put in some kind of retry
policy for stripe to say let's go ahead
and try this stripe call again we could
send another message to strive to be
able to do so or if I want to say try it
five times wait a day tried five times
again that could all be done in the
context of my process manager but if
it's successful then I can notify these
downstream systems so it looks something
like this
receiving the process payment results I
will check to see the success or failure
of that payments so if it didn't succeed
this is where we had the business logic
of what to do based on that so this case
I just I just saying let's just mark the
payment is failed we could do something
like try the stripe payment again keep
track of it inside my process manager
but if if it's successful then at the
bottom what we'll do is go ahead and
publish out a message is saying okay
stripe succeeded we'll go ahead and say
notify downstream systems that our order
was accepted so the final piece is the
RabbitMQ and SendGrid part but I noticed
that syn grid just needs to be notified
when payment was successful so syn grit
could actually just be another
subscriber to this event that payment is
successful just like all the other
downstream systems like the any kind of
fulfillment service in the backend so
same great just becomes yet another
subscriber to that that payments
successful event so the thank-you sender
this is the send grid service now the
same grid endpoint receives the order
accepted event based on the
pushing and says okay now I will go
ahead and send you the think email based
on that or being accepted and that order
accepted events it doesn't care why that
happens so it's not connected to the
business logic about when orders or why
orders that getting accepted it just
gets notified when this occurs okay then
go ahead and perform this additional
operation and all the other different
downstream processes are also connected
to the same individual event so the
fulfillment services or shipping
services they're also connected to this
order except an event so I'm lined up a
picture that looks like this and this
picture is like this is more complicated
right like I'm introducing a lot more
things into the mixer instead of having
everything happening in the single the
context of a single button click now I'm
rate reducing messaging I'm introducing
communication patterns with request
response and pub/sub I'm introducing
this pattern in the middle of this
process manager so this is a lot more
stuff to do but with this with this in
place I have a much higher degree of
success of orders actually getting
processed and when I worked in a large
e-commerce shop this is exactly what we
did we didn't use queues because they
didn't really they were really didn't
exist at the time we had a table that
you said order requests and it is
processed flag and we would just loop
over the table so we basically invented
a queue as part of our order request
process we had an order processor that
did exactly this it would walk through
all the different things that needed to
happen with an order and coordinated the
operations of each of those different
things so this is where Bill and I got
to at the very end he felt very good
about things but we looked at this
picture and we only had one week left on
the contract so this is like this is too
much to do so in real life the thing the
choice we actually picked was about 40
minutes ago sorry in real life we
actually went with the undo action so we
would try to post a payment to stripe
and if that failed then we would just
refund the money because that was all
that the business had appetite to do but
in modern e-commerce systems they start
to introduce these more complex
interaction patterns to be able to get
have a much higher degree of success
with the most important part of the
business
just taking the customers order so if
you want more information about this the
best resource that I have for you is the
poorly named but it's a great great book
enterprise integration patterns and so
all these different patterns we've
talked about this the person that wrote
this Gregg our hope also that coffee
shop doesn't do two-phase commits and so
all the patterns I described here
actually documented as part of this
along with much much more so if we're
interested in reading more about this I
encourage you to check this out
it's not like a Dan Brown book it's on a
page-turner it's very thick it's a
patterns book right so you don't just
read it front to back it also doubles as
a personal safety device so it's very
large and thick so if you're getting
robbed you can smack someone with it but
it is a great book to have around so
thank you very much this was six little
lines of fail I hope you enjoy the rest
of your conference thanks
[Applause]